welcome back 20 years of drought and
climate change has affected
our water supply harvey blankfeld with
las vegas real estate now the sponsor of
this segment
is here to discuss these changes harvey
welcome to the show our first in-studio
guest we appreciate you being here
so how has this affected our water
supply well uh
if you tune in tomorrow on our show on
las vegas real estate now you can hear
bronson mack from the southern nevada
water authority talk about the last 20
years of drought
the good news is jc that for the last 20
years we've actually reduced our
consumption in this valley
even though we added 800 000 residents
we went down 23 percent
and which is remarkable we're doing
something right absolutely the problem
is is that as the drought continues
we need to do even better because as you
can see lake mead is dropping quite a
bit
what is being done to protect our water
supply right now okay so right now they
just they completed this third straw at
the bottom of the lake so we'll have
water for
for the foreseeable future right now
they're also partnering with
southern california i don't know if you
know this but here in southern nevada
all the water we use
internally in our homes gets recycled i
was just talking to someone actually out
at the lake about this so if you're
drinking water in summerlin
and you flush it or you're washing your
car which you shouldn't be that water is
gonna eventually end up it's gonna get
processed and then back in the lake back
in the lake exactly right and now
southern
california is trying to do the same
thing if they can do it the amount of
savings is dramatic of course southern
california huge population
if they can do that and then we will
share in that water because we're going
to help them financially to do that so
we got a team up with california here's
what you got to do
indeed okay what are some of the things
that we can do to conserve water here in
las vegas something people watching
right now
can start doing a conservative okay so
some of the most important things to do
of course is
watch your clocks be monitoring oh by
the way they're smart clocks i just
learned this from bronson the other day
there are smart clocks out there you can
run from your phone
so when it rains you can turn your
system off so smart
right and right now do we all run out to
the clock and do it no but if you had it
on your phone you tell
it's raining i can turn the clock off
and stop the water the other thing is
report abuse i mean don't you know don't
feel like you're a snitch but you're but
you're helping our community
the reason as a realtor i'm here i'm not
an expert on water supply
but i'm concerned about where we're
going to be you know i've been selling
real estate for 20 years where would it
be 20 years from now i want to make sure
we have enough water for our kids
and a great thing too is even if you
live in a community hoa communities here
in las vegas if you see that the
community sprinkler is broken
call your hoa and say hey just you know
the park out front of the complex
there's water going everywhere and
they'll fix it yeah
most of the time that abuse is not is
not intentional it's accidental you know
a head popped off and there's water
spraying so just make somebody aware of
it and then
then it gets fixed it saves water for
everybody the other thing is is that the
legislature recently passed a bill where
they were trying to remove all of the
non-essential
central turf yes which is great and the
way bronson described it any grass that
anybody has
and the only time it's ever stepped on
is when it's mowed we don't need that
grass that's a great way to save money
and save water
as well absolutely harvey we appreciate
you coming on the show and this airs
tomorrow on your show
yeah tomorrow tune at 11 on kdwn you're
going to hear bronson for the whole
basically the whole show we're talking
about water conservation the whole time
beautiful thank you so much harvey we
appreciate it thanks for having me back
thank you las vegas real estate now for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call 702
203 or find them online at
lvrealestateradio.com